[Music]
today we're going to be talking about
technical conversion or defense as we
will see in same-color Bishop M game's
technical same-color Bishop end games
the lesson is going to be quite
complicated the positions despite the
fact that we have limited material are
very often extremely extremely difficult
and complicated the plans are not easy
to find both when you're wanting trying
to convert and also when you're trying
to defend as we will see so any small
mistake can can mean a lot in in the
long run so we have this position first
this is a game between Alexander grace
shook and America's own knack Maura and
in this position grease Chuck has a big
decision to make
he can either preserve the rooks on the
board and try to break black's defense
with them on the board or he can
exchange groups and force force a bishop
and game which one is the right decision
let's try to figure it out if you are at
home watching I would definitely I would
definitely tell you to stop the video
give it some thought maybe 10 to 15
minutes try to understand the position
and then come up with the decision this
is a very good practical exercise as
well as well as just an game
understanding exercise you will find
yourself in this type of situations very
very often so you guys take five minutes
maybe a bit less and then we'll discuss
it okay so what is the initial instinct
in in this position to do what yes
it's very possible and of course this is
the decision he has to make because the
ensuing end game the ensuing bishop
endgame is not easy at all to break as
we will see Greece shock I think I
needed at least 30 more moves after
after the after after this move he
played the role Cape v the problem is if
it goes through b7 and and tries to
enter like this I'm going to go King to
e8 King to e6 and there are ok 6 forcing
you to go back there is not really a
clear way of of making progress and is
the rook is going to be quite active
black rook is going to be quite active
it's going to keep White's pieces are
tied to the defense of his pawns and the
breakthrough and conversion is going to
be extremely difficult and you don't
really know when you're going to have
next chance of actually exchanging the
roofs so we should probably thought for
a while I actually don't know their time
situation and he played the rook to a5
in the position rook takes a5 first
bishop takes a5 Bishop to a 3 and now
once again if you're at home stop the
video try to create a plan try to create
a winning plan and we'll see whether you
achieve doing that or not you guys same
thing how to make progress with white
we have the the black pawn on the dark
square so that's a good thing is going
to potentially become a a weakness in
the future but how are we going to break
through easier said than done of course
of course easier said than done if you
if we would be able to do that then his
uh then the position is easily winning
the problem is he's always going to try
to stop us with the King he's going to
try to mmm correct he's also going to
keep connection with that pawn on d4 at
some point probably we're going to play
the move d5 in order to liberate one of
our pieces and then he's just going to
try to keep opposition with with the
King to try to not allow you to enter
the position so now there is one plan at
least one part of the plan that kind of
has to be done automatically because
it's the only way we can even hope to
break through and that is to bring the
King on the King side via g4 h5 and try
to enter on g6 and at the right moment
maybe we're going to use the D pawn as
as a distraction just just push it give
it away potentially and then break
through with the King on g6 if we manage
to plant a King on g6 then the position
is simply going to be crumbling for
black so as we will see this is easier
said than done
once again because black has some sort
of blocade in the position Bishop to c1
Bishop c5 Bishop e3 a lot of shuffling
as we will see in the next next moves
Bishop to g1 King before now I'm just
going to stay on the c1 h6 diagonal to
try to stop you from coming with the
King right for at least as much as I can
King yay d5 is this a good move
correct correct but if you don't play
the move d5 then how are you going to
continue where exactly exactly well I
mean if you don't do that where's the
winning plan because whenever you try to
move away with the king let's say for
example you go King to d3 and then I go
Bishop c1 and I I guess the only way of
actually going to g4 and h5 would be B
ie 2 but then my King comes and
potentially I'm going to go - I think I
can go to c6 Bishop to d7 and then just
play Bishop g5 or this might be a bit
hasty by me because now this move comes
on the Bourdon and f4 next move I think
I made a mistake
big mistake so king c6 is too hasty I
think I'm just going to stay here try to
block you as much as possible whenever
you go here now I'm going to put my
bishop on III keep connection with the
pawn on d4 and when you try to end ah
can I go king c6 yes I can
but this should be still very much
losing
yeah this is very much losing because
right now Bishop e7 is coming on the
board Bishop e7 and then King before
Bishop takes f6 I think I'm mmm no ff4
is probably a good move as well but I
think that just gives me extra options
as black
I think Bishop e7 just simply takes the
pawn next move no matter what no matter
what you do because you cannot take on
d4 yeah and the King doesn't have moves
the black King doesn't have moves that's
why I like keeping the pawn on f3 it
also controls the e4 square it doesn't
allow my King to to get close to it so
somehow if I have to find a better
defense as black in the case you don't
play the move t5 so after King yet
instead of d5 King D 3
[Music]
I'm I just need to be faster I can I can
I can play King the seven or I can just
simply keep the King well tour oh sorry
I have to defend my bishop first and
then keep the King here
I mean to tie tie the bishop to the
defense of the d4 pawn okay I found the
draw what the draw just the way to
survive now I'm just going to wait and
I'm simply not allowing you to enter to
penetrate via g6 the bishop is immobile
because it has to stay connected to the
d4 pawn and I get that's why we have to
play d5 so that we lessen the bishop
from another burden that of defending
the d4 pawn so let's go back d5 was
played King to d7 Bishop e3 Bishop d4
Bishop to d8 Bishop c3 Bishop e7 king f4
yeah now we're going closer to the point
to the entrance on g6 but it's not over
yet
black still has a lot of resources to
try to defend this position Bishop to d6
King g7 King goes to f7 and the bishop
stays on d6 yeah very important what to
do now let's try to find a winning plan
if you go King h5 I go King up seven you
have to be extremely careful with with
pawn pushes f4 actually I believe it's
going to be a draw
generally I want to keep my pawns on the
light squares
bishop or d2 very good very good mr. can
west of course Bishop d2 with the idea
of playing the move Bishop f4 at I'm not
going to exchange the bishops are as
black that's not going to happen but I'm
going to force to displace the Bishop
from d6 yeah which is a great defender
Bishop c5 Bishop f4 bishop before king
h5 King f7 Bishop d3 Bishop c5 Bishop c5
years what now what's the next step
which was played Bishop d4 again how are
you going to continue the king on f7
he's staying there he's just waiting
he's just waiting
that's what I was saying you have to use
your deep one as as a decoy but don't
hurry
because if you played this seven right
now I go King g7 king g6 King takes d7
and then I'm not sure it's a draw it's
probably still winning after king f7 but
III do want a little bit more precision
from you guys
precision is extremely extremely
important and quite undervalued
he played Bishop h4 he's just simply
preparing to play d7 and he just wants
to have the bishop attacking the f6 pawn
so that he gains the tempo because
that's where we have to focus we have to
force the King to go away to allow our
King to go to g6 and then exchange the
pawn sacrifice the D pawn and in
exchange we get the f6 pawn bishop h4
was played Bishop here
this seven bishop da stubborn King I
don't want to move it away what to do
this is another critical moment so once
again if you're at home stop the video
try to try to create a winning plan all
right
King h6 of course
we're on the right track but still it's
not over it's definitely not over
f4 but once again why would we put the
bishop the pawn on dark squares and then
but we are controlling the important
squares we are already controlling g6
and g7 these are the entry squares by
placing the King on h7 is not
necessarily going to help our cause
Bishop you want sure I'm not going to
take the bishop I'm going to go Bishop
d6
the same going to go here
Bishop c5 and then Bishop d8 let's see
you can reach the same position he
played Bishop before Bishop da whether
you have the Bishop on c5 or on Bishop
is the same thing
so that's the last part of the plan
right yeah exactly
now that we place the bishop on the a3
FA diagonal
the King cannot go to e7 anymore so now
we don't need the King on the quick on
the King side anymore we need it on the
Queen side right now so we're gonna walk
back now now the King goes back exactly
the king goes back King g7 king f4 yes
it's always try to stage your winning
plan this is the first stage I have to
do this in the first stage then I get
there I improve my position a little bit
create another stage come up with the
next part of the plan right and and and
solve the tasks at hand one at a time
right now we're just going there Bishop
f4 and that that's it
hey uh yeah I mean you see how these
three pieces control the blacking very
very well and it's important that we
have this pawn on f3 controlling the
this g4 square right all right so this
was a nice swim but to be honest Greece
Chuck had to see all this all this ideas
since Ruka five since move number one
because if he traced the rooks and he
doesn't have an entry like this then the
position is just simply a drop but you
don't necessarily need to calculate yeah
you just need to imagine the positions
in in your in your head and that's not
as difficult don't calculate move by
move because you're going to get lost
imagine the pieces where the pieces
should be placed and see if there is any
impediment new reaching those positions
generally it isn't because black is what
the defending side is always going to
have his hands full you know with
something he's not going to be able to
necessarily create counter play what
he's basing his defense on is a blockade
you are not necessarily counter play in
this situation so he also had to see the
idea of pushing the deep on using it as
a decoy and forcing basically the
blacking know the black position the
black pieces into full passivity yeah
with the bishop on the a the King on f7
then cutting the King that was the last
plan and bringing the King back to the
other side so I'm pretty sure grease
chuck understood this when he decided to
play a rook to a five okay let's go to
the next one in which we're going to see
how Maxim vascular Grove managed to
defend a very very difficult position
and we have this position rocked a ch5
King takes h5 what to do what to do how
to set up the defense where is the
defense if there is one
what is black going what is Black's
winning plan how are you good well right
right right right so I think pushed upon
is dangerous once you put it on on a
five that's just going to be a weakness
to be honest reliability for your
position you're going to need the bishop
on the d8 a5 diagonal to defend that a
five points so be very careful with
pushing your pawns on the same on the
same color as your bishop
now most probably the winning plan in
this position should be an intrusion
with the king and the only path is
continued
yeah exactly if we can get to d1 most
probably we're going to have good chance
of winning nevertheless getting to d1 is
not going to be an easy task because you
have I'm going to keep the kingdom to d3
and you're going to have to pass through
e1 yeah you're going to have to firstly
displace my bishop that's not going to
be an easy task it's doable though as we
will see
so what's White's mechanism in this type
of positions you kind of as I was
mentioning at the end of the last
problem you have to kind of build
technical mechanisms in your mind
understand how to arrange your pieces so
why it started with the move b3
obviously this is a good technical move
you're placing your pawn on the light
square it's not going to be a potential
target for the blacks Bishop let's see
how to continue King to g4
Bishop d2 King to f3 Bishop to e1
well I think first first thing that we
need to do is just get the Gator king to
f1 mm-hmm so that we're ready to enter
to e1 at any moment he play King g2
Bishop the tube king f2 or f1 Bishop to
b4 a6
another good technical move we're
placing our well the attackers spawn on
the lights course Bishop d2 there's no
hurry
yeah we can wait and see what what our
opponent is going to do especially if
you're on the defending side even
psychologically is going to be extremely
difficult to just survive for long
periods of time so the longer the game
goes the higher the chance the defender
is going to blunder something or is
going to miss a certain defensive
resource Bishop to g7 Bishop c3 Bishop
f4 as we will see some shuffling of the
pieces going on Bishop before King to f1
okay so now what we're going to try to
do is put the Bishop to e1 potentially
drag the bishop off the diagonal and
force it onto which diagonal
well c1h six diagonal that's not going
to stop working from reaching d1 right
he has to go on the h4e one dag yeah but
that one is a little bit shorter yeah so
we will see that plays a very important
role
Bishop c3 Bishop g5 were not in a hurry
Bishop h4 bishop p1 bishop da bishop
before Bishop h4 you're still not
answering not yet at least
what to do it's difficult it's difficult
to get that King away and that Bishop
away the only way of doing that is it by
brute force or is it by something else
so it's one exactly mm-hmm it's not easy
to achieve that suze one but it's it's
doable
if you could put the bishop where with
an immediate suzong be take the bishop
off the board the the the blacks bishop
and put it anywhere you want on the
board correct
Bishop f4 that would be a truth one
right so let's try to get it there he
started off with the move Bishop to a3
because right now if you go something
like Bishop g3 I think I'm going to go
Bishop c1 now if you go Bishop h4 I go
Bishop f4 and that's about it
and if you go King C - I'm going to go
ah I can also enter Bishop F - I think
Bishop here and then Bishop f2 and then
I enter with a king on f1 or even easier
to go well I don't know about easier but
I can also do this Bishop g5 and you're
again in suits one because your Bishop
doesn't have squares so white played a
good prophylactic move came to d2
stopping that a bishop from reaching c1
the problem persists how to do how to
continue
Bishop b2
yes yes Bishop d2 he's just going to
defend with Bishop f6 I'm trying to
think whether I can do something else
no Bishop f6 makes a lot of sense hmm
Bishop to d6 you mean Bishop to d6 okay
that's why he played but what to do how
to continue
very good
Bishop h2 of course now your instance
one if you go Bishop f2 I go Bishop g1
now that's why you have to put a bishop
on h2 not anywhere else on the diagonal
because otherwise I would have extra
moves if you go king of three I go
Bishop g1 I attack your opponent d4 then
you have to move the the bishop off the
h41 diagonal and then I'd penetrate with
the king king he wanting the two etc
game over yeah so is it or loss
it's not all lost as we will see it's
not I mean we're not there at the
critical moment just yet it looks as if
it's lost it looks as if the black King
goes to d1 the game is over
fortunately for for white we have
another line of defense and that is the
h61 diagonal now yeah because I'm going
to put the King on d3 and then you're
going to have to pass through c1
together so he played King to d3 King do
you want Bishop d2 alright
how come back how can black continue
trying to make any progress you know we
have to displace the bishop from which
that correct Bishop d6 a3 and c1 right
to displace the bishop from the c1 h6
diagonal I think is the only square
where we can do that wrong so of course
that's where he went he went mission g5
Bishop to a3 this is it I'm going to
give you a few minutes just try to kind
of Basking all the information you
received and try to understand whether
white has any more chances or not maybe
calculate if you're at home you're
probably going to need a lot more time
you can give yourself even half an hour
in this position I gave I gave you this
position like 24 hundredths and they
have the they had difficulties finding
the difference but we know Bashir is an
extremely extremely powerful defender
can well king c3 I'm going to go kinky -
this is more or less a study like
defense wait excuse me what
Kingsley tricking it - yeah yeah yeah
Kingsley tricking it - so let's see
let's see Bishop d2 yeah that definitely
deserves our attention or for that
reason Bishop f4 and now Bishop d6 right
and whenever we move the bishop on DC 1
no h6 diagonal we will try to stop your
entrance with Bishop 8 3 Bishop d2
extremely good move Bishop to c5 you
still cannot go King see one because
Bishop e3 and now your Bishop on d2 is
under attack Bishop - you won now King
c1 becomes a threat if I managed to if I
managed to bring the King to a B 2 or B
1 for that our respective matter then
the position is just were losing so
bishop it Bishop e3 has to be played is
this a drop
hmm which were yes absolutely how to how
to make progress though seems like why
it has some sort of blockade but maybe
he doesn't there's one thing you you
need to understand in this position and
it's a technique that you use it in many
many types of n games can anybody tell
me what you need to understand it's
black to move and that's exactly what
you need to understand you need to
understand that is black to move if it
would be white to move he's in suits one
it's a good question mm-hmm
if I've definitely seems like like the
right move but that's something we have
to be once again very careful with
because if we put the pawn on on a dark
square it might cost us a weakness so
let's see let's see i-5 let's see a five
it's definitely an interesting move I'm
gonna try to defend I don't know if
there is a difference but I think there
is we shall be to Bishop before so that
was his that was his idea because once
again in this position if white is to
move he's going to have to make a
concession he goes Bishop b2 then we go
Bishop before and then he's kind of in
Sudan once again he has to allow us to
get the King to see one or two c2 if he
moves with the king so the problem is
the only way in this particular case to
lose tempo is with the move with the
move a5 it seems
but I don't like creating that weakness
there I'm going to try to take advantage
of that somehow not sure if there is a
widow let this might this might work
this might just simply win right that's
the thing if you go push a bit - I'm
gonna go Bishop before if you move the
bishop on the other side like Bishop c5
or something like that then I just go
king c1
here we shall pay three king b1 now in
threatening King eight - that's the
problem that's a big problem right and
it seems like we're losing that point I
think so wait if I was any interesting
and if I go here you go here bishop
they seems to be losing
yeah
maybe a five is winning as well hmm
maybe a five is winning as well
okay King c1 King be too
III
now what this should be losing right
yeah I think even with even without this
point is is losing because I'm going to
go King c4 and then I'm going to put you
into zone
you're going to have to give give me the
d4 pawn so still quite puzzled because
just I thought there was a defense but
for some reason I cannot find it right
now I don't think you're gonna be in
time it's a good tribe but I don't think
you're gonna be in time and even even if
even if you take this pawn I'm going to
put my king to see for your king is very
far from from the a pond and then I'm
just going to use my Bishop to promote
the point yeah and then RA for
you should before but even even like
that I think should be losing like for
example if you go Bishop f8 let's say go
a bit further and then yeah you know
there's plenty of ways to win this
position I carry I can even just take
this pawn and then play Bishop c5 and
then even if you managed to sack the
pawn I have the other one yeah I have
the D pawn this is a bit annoying that I
cannot find the defense ok we'll leave
it as a 5 is winning as well even though
I there should be a defense that I'm I'm
missing right now I would cheat and use
the engine but I don't want to do that
yeah okay so let's let's say if I'm is
winning as well let's just let's just
say there it is oh okay
so maybe a better defense as white yep
opposition correct very good king c3
brilliant defense after King e2b for now
I'm threatening to play King b3
so now King D 1 has to be played support
Bishop c1 King b3 Bishop c1 Bishop takes
c1 king c1 King c3 opposition and you
don't have moves
a5 doesn't work if I've doesn't work and
wherever you go I'm going to follow you
you're here so here so here you're here
like this or here actually whenever you
go here to get you correct
let's see I think you might actually be
losing so you have to be very careful
you can get a bit a bit too greedy too
greedy and then you lose because you
have to take because you have to take
one extra pawn and then in the meantime
he defends the other one so but yeah you
just keep opposition at all times and
it's just a draw yeah
so very nice defense by white with this
move King to c3 so now he played a5 and
now it's a bit different than what we
were trying to analyze previously
because right now the bishop is the
white bishop is on a different diagonal
it's on the h6
see one diagonal which is a longer
diagonal previously it was on a3 the
position we were trying to decipher
earlier so right now I think it's still
a draw because that a 5-point can be
used as as a weakness for y so Bishop c1
bishop d8 attacking the weakness Bishop
to d2 what to do now
only move Bishop z7 Bishop c7 I'm going
to go king c1
and then I'm going to move my bishop and
then I'm going to play King b2
Bishop e7 yeah so that whenever he goes
king c1 we go Bishop e3 King c1 Bishop
e3 King d1 shuffling a little bit now
I'm gonna go Bishop before Bishop g5 and
that's it draw yeah
there's no way to make any progress
anymore the problem is you have the pawn
on e5 that's that's liability that just
allows me to make a make a draw so yeah
that was it
never lose hope as a defender because
there is a lot of blockades in this type
of Industry of Bishop and games yeah as
an attacker you should always try to
displace your opponent's you're the
defenders bishop from the longer the
longer diagonal the shorter diagonal if
that's possible the shorter the diagonal
the less moves he has and the easier is
going to be for you to try to place him
in Seussville yeah which is a very very
useful technical method to try to win
and convert this type of end games so
you have suits Vance you have
triangulation as well and I'm really
really curious to see one of your games
maybe for next time or whenever you find
me around bring me one of your games if
you can remember one time that you had
this type of end games and maybe we can
look at it but yeah that was it
that's class endgame exclam
[Music]
you
[Music]